ترى? السودان يدخل منعطفا خطيرا
قد يؤدي به الى الهلاك. رأيكم هل
المدن. فهذا يعلن السيطرة على
المطار وعدد من المناطق الحيوية
تصاعد للدخان نجاة رئيس الوزراء
الياباني شيدا محاولة اغتيال
الضباط ليرد الجيش باصدار قرار
يقضي بحل قوات الدعم السريع
مقاتلات اف ستة عشر الامريكية
عقب انضمام فنلندا الى حلف
في تحول مفاجئ للصراع بينهما
نزاع مسلح في الخرطوم وفي عدد من
السريع شبه العسكري الموالية
لحليفه السابق محمد حمدان دجلو.
السودانيون عليكم بالحوار قبل ان
يقع الفأس بالرأس واسألوا العرب
المدنيين لم يتم حصرهم بعد وفق
لجنة اطباء السودان المركزية.
الخرطوم وعدد من المدن ليمهلهم
الجيش وقتا قصيرا للانسحاب لكن
السوداني انضمت الى قواتها
بقيادة المفتش العام وعدد من
الناتو وسط مشاهد هلع ودور في
المكان بعد سماع دوي انفجار تلاه
هنا قالت قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان ان عناصر من الجيش
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
والمانيا واليابان وايطاليا
للدولة. وذاك ينفي او يعلن
استعادتها. وبين هذا وذاك دخل
وانهاء انتداب جميع ضباط وافراد
الجيش لديها على خلفية الاحداث
للقوى السبع الصناعية. حيث تضم
بريكس البرازيل وروسيا والهند
مطار الخرطوم ومطار مروي دائرة
الاشتباكات. وتم احراق بعض
باسم الرئاسة التركية ابراهيم
دولن تسريع انقرة لصفقة شراء
ماذا جنوا من الحروب الداخلية؟
الاحداث والتطورات اعلن المتحدث
خلال كلمته بحملته الانتخابية.
فهل هي رسالة من كيم جونغ يا
دون جدوى فحدثت الكارثة. حيث
اندلعت المواجهات بين القوات
الطائرات المدنية ليسقط عدد كبير
جدا من الضحايا والمصابين من
الجارية في البلاد. فماذا بعد
هذا اليوم الدامي ايها
دامية جدا. وبعد عامين من خلافات
سياسية بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
كارثية. وها هو السودان يعيش
وضعا صعبا بل لنقل حربا قد تكون
الدعم السريع. انتشرت قوات الدعم
السريع في مروي شمالي السودان ثم
الى الابد? السودان يشتعل. بل لا
يتعظ بمصير غيره يحصل على نتائج
والصين وجنوب افريقيا. واضف
عليها السعودية وتركيا والجزائر
وكندا والاتحاد الاوروبي. فهل
تكتب البريكس نهاية مجموعة السبع
التي يقودها الفريق اول
عبدالفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم
تحت مناقشة الانضمام. بينما
مجموعة السبع فرنسا والولايات
وضع الدولار الامريكي كعملة
احتياط. اتحدت العديد من اكبر
بشكل ملح منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا. وكشفت الارقام الاخيرة
سيلفا ليوقع الجانبان عددا من
الاتفاقيات الاقتصادية والتجارية
الامريكي واستخدامه في التجارة
العالمية. وهذا ما تناقشه منظمة
بحرب حقيقية على الارض. نعم يا
التنين الصيني على المسار الصحيح
عن تفوق مجموعة لاول مرة على دول
مجموعة السبع الاكثر تقدما في
على حدودها مع روسيا بعد
انضمامها الى الناتو خوفا من
النائمة. فهل تكفي هذه السياجات
لمنع تدفق جيش بوتين المظلم ومن
بوتين مشروع قانون بشأن وضع
اجراءات للاستدعاء الالكتروني
جانبا. ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان الصين
والبرازيل اتفقتا على خطة موت
يانديكس ورملر وجاز برو. بكين
تضرب اقتصاد امريكا في مقتل.
الدول اقتصاديا واكثرها اكتظاظا
بالسكان لاطلاق بديل للدولار
العالم. وذلك بعد ان بلغت مساهمة
بريكس واحدا وثلاثين ونصف
بالمائة في الاقتصاد العالمي
مقابل ثلاثين فاصل سبعة بالمائة
زيننسكي فقد رشق الشركات الروسية
بالعقوبات وفرض عقوبات لمدة عشر
فيما بينهما. وبعد سنوات مما
تراه بعض الدول اساءة لاستخدام
بهدف زيادة كفاءة التعبئة
العسكرية وسد الثغرات. اما
للدولار الامريكي. بعد اعلان
التعامل التجاري العملات المحلية
التهديدات لا تكفي والتصريحات لا
تفيد. ولابد من خطوات عملية
سنوات ضد الشركات الروسية في
مجال التقنيات الرقمية شملت
المهمة باعتبار الصين اكبر شريك
تجاري للبرازيل منحية امريكا
ازمة هجرة قد تفتعلها انهم
يقصدون جواسيس بوتين وخلاياه
لتنتصر الصين في حربها الباردة
مع امريكا. فلربما تأتي الايام
وهو الرئيس الصيني شيجن بينغ
يستقبل نظيره البرازيلي لولادا
كي يتم تحليلها ودراستها واكتشاف
استراتيجية صنعها وكما يقولها
الروسية والتي لم تكن مريحة
للفنلنديين. فنلندا تبني سياجا
فنلندا الى قلب العاصمة الروسية
موسكو. حيث وقع الرئيس فلاديمير
العرب اليمنيون مع مصلي الا
وطالب مغفرة. وبسبب التحركات
تبحث في نفايات امريكا ودول
اوروبا الفضائية عن بقايا حطام
روسية. حتى ان مدير عام مؤسسة
الفضائية الدولية يوري بروسوف لم
يؤثر على علاقات واشنطن
بشركائها. لكن تسريب الوثائق لا
بوتين سنجيبكم نحن. روسيا لا
تهرول عبثا من اجل الفضاء بل هي
النفايات الفضائية في مدار الارض
وفق ما اوردته وسائل اعلام
ولتنظر حينها هل اثرت التسريبات
عندها ام لا? ومن حرب المعلومات
النفايات ضمنا. فعن اي فضاء نووي
يتحدث هؤلاء ما الذي يخطط له
على تطوير مشروع درب التبانة
الفيدرالي والذي شأنه تتبع
عسكريا الى جانب روسيا انه لامر
صعب ومعقد للغاية. لكن لا شيء
ان علاقات مع الولايات المتحدة
مبنية على الثقة. مضيفا انهم
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن بان
تسريب وثائق البنتاجون السرية لم
تنازل بلاده عن اراض لها هي امر
خاطئ سياسيا وقانونيا واخلاقيا
الى فضاء بوتين النووي. حيث وافق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يستبعد استخدام قاطرة فضائية
نووية لتنظيف مدار الارض من
يصعب على اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
ومع ذلك فعداد القتل اوكرانيا
حتى تعبيره. وبخصوص الوثائق
المسربة فقد صرح وزير الخارجية
على الاسلحة المطلوبة. واشار
كوليبي الى ان اي خطة سلام تتضمن
ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانية في
جمهوريتي لوجانس ودونيسك وتصفية
اكثر من اربعمائة وستين جنديا
اوكرانيا في كافة المحاور حسب
في الاسلحة الروسية المستخدمة في
اوكرانيا بحسب وكالة رويترز.
تصريحهم. ليخرج وزير الخارجية
الاوكراني ديمتروكوريبا. ويقول
يجري بسرعة كبيرة. حيث افادت
وزارة الدفاع الروسية بتدمير
فالحان الوقت لتكشف بكين عن
نفسها كاول دولة في العالم تقف
ان كييف مصرة على خروج اخر جندي
روسي واستعادة كل الاراضي. واكد
الاوكرانية عثرت على عدد متزايد
من المكونات الالكترونية الصينية
يسعون لتحويل مشكلة تسريب
الوثائق الى فرصة لتسريع الحصول
يزال طازجا يا هذا بل تهدئ من
روعك قليلا لتظهر بقية المعلومات
تعد لوحدها حيث قال مستشار في
مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني القوات
الدفاع الدانماركية ان دبابات
ليو بارك وان الدانمارك المانية
تغني الدبابات الاوكران او تسمنه
من جوع لا يبدو ذلك. فروسيا لم
المانية دنماركية هولندية بشأن
تسليم ما لا يقل عن مائة دبابة
عن هدية عظيمة ومهمة الى
اوكرانيا وذلك باعلان وزارة
السلاح وبعض من الذخيرة. فهل
ياتي المدد? نعم هنا يصل الدعم
من طراز الى القوات المسلحة
الاوكرانية وفق وكالة تاز. فهل
الغربي والبسمة تعود للملامح
الاوكرانية. حيث تحدثت الدنمارك
وبحرا وجوا. والاوكرانيون
ينتظرون رأفة الغرب بقليل من
المحقق. روسيا تضع يدها في حناجر
الامريكية. الروس يهجمون برا
اربع وعشرين ساعة. وكييف تكشف عن
وجود اسلحة صينية في المعارك
تحديه لكوريا الشمالية رئيس
الوزراء الياباني ينجو من الموت
الامريكي وتركيا تحصل على مكافأة
انضمام فنلندا للناتو. وبعد
فما الذي ينوي فعله? البرازيل
والصين تكتبان نهاية الاقتصاد
الجدار لصد اسلحة الروس? بوتين
يحضر قاطرة نووية لمشروع فضائي.
الاوكرانية فيما فنلندا تبني
عازلا امام روسيا فهل يكفي
الصنع ستكون جاهزة للشحن الى
اوكرانيا وهذا جزء من اتفاقية
على اشدها والمواطنون يعيشون
وضعا حرجا. فما الذي يجري هدية
مفاجئ للصراع. عدوى وحمى الحروب
تنتقل الى السودان. الاشتباكات
الارض. واربعمائة وستون جنديا
اوكرانيا في عداد القتلى خلال
عظيمة ومهمة من الدنمارك
لاوكرانيا قد تحسم المعارك على
يعود السودانيون عن حربهم هذه
قبل ان